[Music]
what do you guys think
happens when we die oh god
the first thing you do is you fart and
you [ __ ] on yourself yeah for your body
or your spirit
both you fart into the existence
that's what i think i really think that
our soul is like a ball of energy and we
just get just
distributed to the we come out of our
own anuses though the spirit i hope so
i don't know that would be the best way
to go do you think you know
when you're about to die like animals
like
like not not like from an accident not
like a sidekick right
but like you know if you're holding your
breath under water
the last like couple of like 10-20
seconds you're like oh [ __ ] i'm out of
breath
do you think there's a oh [ __ ] i'm out
of life i think yeah isn't that like
i'm gonna die
emt is or something didn't we hear from
someone i forgot where i got this in
front oh yeah someone said that
a chemical that gets released in your
brain the moment you die and then dmt
the drug replicates that chemical so
what i'm saying is do you know the
moments before
do you think you i think so that sounds
like a party because if i do
i think i'm gonna start jacking off
right away oh right so you want to time
your day you have this lengthy deathbed
i don't think i'll be able to because if
it's like i'll take your babies
yeah as quick as 10 or 20 seconds but
maybe
i can at least die with a boner you
think you get it up that fast
when you know you're about to die like
you're scared or whatever no he can't
you don't believe in me
i don't think you can do it well explain
why you
think he can't do it yeah explain
because i have sex with him
and i know he can't do it
i honestly when you ask that i'm like
does she really need to explain i
don't know i don't know i don't i don't
think there's an explanation needed well
maybe they
they i don't know okay fine whatever all
right so i asked you you guys had sex
yeah only one time all for taika reasons
all right so the reason why i'm asking
what happens when we die
a new netflix series uh called surviving
death
oh i love these stories when did is it
out already uh
you just interrupted it speaks to people
we don't know what it is
uh i think it's out already yeah i don't
know you know what else is out on date
uh netflix leftovers for david so you
guys gonna watch
that's true check out david's new show i
hate that i like it
if you if you want to see all of david's
pissed off faces
the whole time is just like fast
is he just talking bad [ __ ] to all the
people cooking
no he's just that's just how he is yeah
he's really nice he has really good
critique but he he has resting
[ __ ] face so when he's standing there
he's just [ __ ]
mad he didn't look so mean when he was
fatter
really do you think his like skinny
david like skinny face is just
johnny hill again droopy yeah no he just
looks mad
the whole time oh my gosh well i don't
know
uh that sounds like an amazing show want
to check it out it's about
uh people that use leftovers to make
food
this show is about interviewing people
that have
had a brush with the afterlife yes and
came
back to life so what did they all see
why do they call that near death
experience where
you actually did technically yeah like
their heartbeat stopped
near full death maybe they didn't come
back it was a death experience
permadeath partial death yeah but there
should be another term
non-permanent permanent death experience
yes i like that better
i like that slightly dead that's better
than me or death like diet death
diet i like that i like diet zero
get zero that's your death sample
all right so there's a so
like a sneak peek okay keep going i'll
workshop this
i like death feet that's cool that's
cool it sounds like the peak
yeah yeah that's why i got a workshop i
gotta work on it yeah yeah bring the
death down a little bit yeah
that oh death desperatizer
that's interesting are you a depthizer
yeah i did die once
it was a french version of appetizer le
petit
i don't know pasta
oh that's italian that's italian yeah
yeah whatever i was like that's true
it's on the menus all the time
all right anyways back to the show hors
d'oeuvres yeah
okay so surviving death um they
interview a few people
and they've highlighted a few different
answers and this seems to be kind of
like
the popular experience oh i hope it's a
good one
it's actually very very very pleasant
yes every
so they've highlighted five people here
in this article i don't know and
probably more people in the show
but out of these five people they've all
said that it was
a very warm and comforting wow
that's why they want to go die huh and
the the lasting effects is that they're
no longer afraid of death
wow that's the craziest part now and
then
and mind you um some of these goodness
were wired that way religious
and some of these people weren't
religious and ironically
some of the religious people after
having experienced this
are no longer religious religious and
then some of the non-religious people
became religious became religious yeah
so it's a very life-changing experience
so it's kind of like like when women
have babies and then like chemicals get
released and like it's just like a whole
bunch of like there's connection to your
baby there's also you forget
what it was like to give birth and go
through all that so then you could have
more kids
yeah and then like that's why i'm like
dude our creators had our backs
they're like you're gonna you're gonna
be pleasant i know huh
oh so this is hell we're in hell we're
in hell now
well this is hell keep me going
all right i like hell so one of the
experiences
um said that they met a shadowy figure
uh in their like death did they say
what's your name uh they didn't they
weren't they weren't able to talk
so this person was i had a motorbike
accident this is
british uh bikes uh motorcycle accidents
i like motorbike better motorbikes
yeah i'm reading the article so it
sounds so much better
it makes more sense yeah uh we'll go
with motorbike then
uh this person had a motorbike accident
and lost his arm punctured lungs oh my
internal damage lost loss of blood and
um during the nine hours they operated
on him his heart stopped three times
three times and uh and he doesn't know
whether or not he had this experience
during that time
on the operating table when his heart
stopped or whether it was the
coma that he had to go through for
several weeks after the operation oh
[ __ ]
he has no idea when it happened she
should have paid attention but during
you
have a watch in the afterlife like oh
[ __ ] right now this is the time
you have a spiritual notepad i thought i
didn't have a physical watch because his
arm is over here that's like you said i
know
you try to raise these like ah [ __ ] it's
like beetlejuice
have you watched me like why don't you
laugh you're so mean it's all the
commercial
i'm not mean this is facts like i'm
speaking factually i got robin i'm like
why do you got a lavish [ __ ]
i watch commercial you're gonna rub it
in [ __ ] though
all right uh so then uh during his uh
near
death experience um he at the bottom so
he was kind of laying there and he
he understood that he was laying in a
bed he was laying down
and through his vision he saw he he had
like he was visited by a black shadowy
figure
all right no no gender just a shadowy
figure and
uh didn't say anything but was just
there and this person was
they were non-binary huh non-binary yes
and they were always at the foot of his
bed
and there sounds like a ghost home they
were just there
it seems like the man in black right
like the guy that comes and collects
your soul right
it sounds like samuel l jackson you're
dead [ __ ]
i mean was it a sh like dark blob like i
want to be
i want i want him to draw a shadowy
figure for
whatever that means to you because i
that's all it really gives you
i've seen a shadow we figured before
really
one time i was uh i had sleep paralysis
and
my door was creak like creaked open you
have diet death
it was uh during dreaming so like diet
diet
death probably also you died in your
dreams i don't know
but um but yeah it was like one of those
like sleep paralysis moments and like i
was laying down and i opened my eyes and
at the foot of my bed
that's where the door was and then it
was like slightly open
and so i saw like the shadowy figure
like peeking in but
they had glowing eyes what kind of color
red it always changes between red and
green like my memory can't
grab onto one saw it and then they they
did they have lasers or anything
no it was just like glowing either they
walked away they were like
so your memory is colored wrong door and
then they left
no they didn't touch the door oh they
just picked their hold on move either i
was i was
i wanted to scream because it scared me
i was 11. i remember i was 11 years old
so so they just peeked and then they
walked away well they i don't know i
didn't see them walk away
i couldn't move and then i just closed
my eyes to like make it go away and i
went back to sleep so death came and
they were like oh wrong room
no i just sleep paralysis
[ __ ] you did it again so like if these
shadowy figures are around
all the time what if they're like aliens
with a cloak
could be could be yeah or makers
could be they're like hey dude just rest
up
can you imagine being our babysitter
that [ __ ] sucks dude i would hate to
be a guardian angel like
you want to be your babysitter i'm
pretty chill
i mean no i mean just like the caretaker
like you just gotta watch all day you're
like oh you guys having all this fun
i'll get
do it in the shadow world and [ __ ] i
just gotta follow this [ __ ]
imagine if someone was boring as hell
you're just like why can't you just go
out like come on man you just play
video games all day and they're just
sitting on the bed just waiting
for something fun to happen what a shady
[ __ ] life dude
shadow guys if you're out there man
thank you for the [ __ ] work that you
do
i don't know if you're protecting us or
whatever you're doing but that's some
awesome [ __ ] man
well what else did this guy say about
shadow dude so yeah so
he spent five weeks in the hospital and
this guy was always there at the foot of
his bed and even when he went home
this person was at the foot of his bed
and like it was one of those where
he would it would be there but then he
would rub his eyes or whatever
trying to find it and like actually like
analyze what's happening
and it'll be gone but when he's not like
actually paying attention there would be
a presence you could feel it and
like he could see that there was like a
shadowy figure there it's one of those
things and
uh he would later on uh
uh a study like this this happening of
his
and in a lot of spiritual circles they
call this the third man
and this is like there's more than one
one who's the second one
and the first one i guess like uh i
don't know i don't know why they call it
a third
man but they they say a usually unseen
being that intervenes at critical
moments to give
comfort maybe most spiritual
me that's you and then that's him third
guy father son holy i don't know
wow i mean yeah so they no idea
they probably just chill at the hospital
then because they're like all these
people need me
it's more convenient here if they were
an efficient dude they wouldn't go into
the wild because it's like
where's a human i gotta help right now
that's true they could teleport
oh that's true i don't know their
technology
yeah and i thought this part was really
cool he said before the accident i'd
been religious always praying before bed
but now i felt
i didn't need to do that anymore i felt
religion was a man-made construct
but that there was an afterlife and a
spiritual world and i'd
made a connection well how does he know
that it wasn't through that
through that specifically he's like you
don't look like jesus i'ma start praying
to the shadow man now
he made his own religion i know i don't
know but yeah
uh just to go through the list uh so
there was the shadow man
there was i could see myself in the
hospital bed
uh experience where there was a light
kind of like the heaven light and
she was being lifted and then she came
back down and and during this like
lifting and seeing herself in the bed it
was very comforting and calm and
peaceful
and then another person said they spoke
to their dead grandma who died three
years earlier and it was also very
comforting
and very peaceful and then uh scenes
from life
uh scenes from my life flash before me
and this person was flung outside the
car
through the window but in that moment
her life flashed before her and as she
landed
she said she couldn't feel a thing and
people thought she was dead and she was
like no i'm actually alive
don't don't don't like assume i'm dead
and basically she
kind of like had this very calm but very
like just
like it it seems like they can't they
don't even have the words to really
describe it fully
but it's like it's it's always calm and
i find that very fascinating
i like to hear that interesting how
we're wired huh yeah
we're just like flesh computers yeah
yeah totally
that last one reminded me of a dream i
had where i was dead but then i was like
staring at
the sky and i'm like oh no isaac doesn't
have a mom anymore oh [ __ ] yeah
like i i was really like i was panicking
but that feeling though of like
i don't know it's [ __ ] it's like
panicky but then also
like in their experience it's like
actually calming too yeah that's very
ironic
i don't know it's crazy but yeah but
that's yeah it sounds like a fascinating
documentary it's on netflix called
surviving death
yeah i want to watch it i checked it out
that's cool
[Music]
you